How to write a cover letter.
Now that you've worked out your resume to an almost staggering perfection,...
...what's next for you to do is to create a powerful cover letter.
HR professionals have often suggested that the cover letter is what really gets read.
This means that your cover letter should be just as compelling as your resume.
Remember that you're about to submit an application package,...
...so your cover letter should match your resume in presentation and style.
Also, make an effort to get the name of the hiring authority you'll be addressing your letter to.
This sends out a message that you're genuinely interested in joining a particular company...
...rather than just finding another job.
Try not to put in those details already in your resume.
Instead, pack your cover letter up with statements that grab attention.
Candidates often forget that their application is supposed to meet a need in the company.
Your cover letter should focus on their requirements and how your qualifications can meet them.
Employers should realize that hiring you is the solution.
Lastly, your cover letter and resume are two different playing cards.
Even if your cover letter should summarize your resume,...
...make sure to use it as an added means to express your value to the organization.